hi there steve kaufman here to talk
again about language learning from a
different perspective
we all know that motivation is the key
to language learning success
beyond anything else method school
whatever motivation is the driver of
success in language learning
now
in the english-speaking world
uh being monolingual
is the norm all right but there are many
societies but that's not the case
uh
in certain countries in europe for
example in singapore
in ethiopia
there are many places where being bi or
multilingual is the norm
and i don't think people in those places
are any different
so the difference is the motivation now
you can say that the circumstances in
those countries where many languages
coexist uh
that that's the reason but that in fact
is just a factor that contributes to
motivation all right
so and in the world so we have
monolingual people
typically in the english speaking world
in large countries you know japan russia
china
uh brazil
uh where people are less motivated to
learn
uh amongst the people who speak more
than one language you have
sort of people who speak two or three or
four
and we call them the multilingual people
bilingual multilingual and then you have
the so-called polyglots
who are motivated to go and learn more
and and also i think there's a
distinction between those who learn
languages for
professional or practical reasons and
those who learn languages as an
adventure in order to explore different
cultures travel meet people
get to know more of of the
people who are living at this time
with us and so on and so on so there's
these different distinctions however
it all begins at the beginning and
that's the gist of what i want to talk
about and that is
this idea that in language learning
you may not think that you're motivated
but
you know i encourage people who don't
think they're motivated to learn
languages to just do it
and i'm going to give some background to
that first of all there is an expression
that is attributed to aristotle
well begun is half done
so in other words just get started and
you'll be well on your way
and it reminds me
in my life how
just by committing myself to doing
something
this has brought all kinds of other
unintended or unforeseeable advantages
and i was reminded of that because i
received an email
from a swedish business associate
a person and his company we did business
for almost 20 years he and his wife
visited us here in palm springs
and he sent me a graph
of the sudden spike in north american
lumber prices in 1993 which is precisely
when
i contacted him in order to have wood
lumber supplied from sweden to japan
now how was i able to contact this
person well
back in nine two or three years earlier
in my young company because i created my
lumber company in 1987 and we had
different projects but one of our
projects was to develop
lumber supply from canada to europe and
so we hired a european lumber
grading expert to help us develop
product for europe and we were selling
uh lumber graded to european standards
in various markets in europe and of
course the grading expert we hired was
from sweden so i developed these
contacts in sweden
then when lumber prices in north america
spiked it was no longer possible to
export lumber from north america to
europe because their prices were lower
and north american prices were higher so
that the producing
mills in north america no longer wanted
to make
products for a lower priced market but
because i had initiated all of that
activity i realized that there now was a
different opportunity i could bring wood
from europe to japan and today my
company is importing wood from europe to
north america so
just by having committed myself to
developing
wood for the european market i developed
contacts which ultimately helped me
develop and maintain this other business
so you never know what's going to lead
to what uh the same has been true in in
my language learning activities uh i
you know i got interested in french i
ended up going to france because i
studied in france therefore i was
accepted into the canadian diplomatic
service i mean i could go on and on the
point is
if you do something if you commit to
doing something like nothing
everything in this world is a matter of
opportunities that are waiting to happen
and you are either going to
get out there and do things that cause
these opportunities to come your way or
you sit back and do nothing so
with languages again
uh you know i i follow on twitter people
like holy richards who's now in japan
and he sends these lovely pictures of
the countryside in shikoku and he
committed to learning japanese and now
he's traveling in japan and having a
wonderful
cultural culinary whatever tourist
experience
and so you never know right right now
i'm i'm learning arabic um
it's been two and a half months or so
not progressing too badly i'm not not
unhappy with my progress it's tough but
what is this going to lead to what kinds
of opportunities what kinds of people am
i going to meet what kind of travel what
am i going to discover about
you know
arabic and that whole culture and
civilization and and once i've learned
the arabic writing that'll lead me on to
farsi and discovering more about
uh you know middle east uh central asia
and so forth so
all i'm saying is there's a phenomenal
world out there that awaits people who
take on at first one new language
and possibly another new language
and whether you are learning for
practical reasons
or
as an adventurer as an explorer or both
you can expect
more wonderful things to happen to you
if you commit
take that first step down this path
and i think in my own case i started out
as a bit of an explorer exploring french
then i had some professional reasons to
learn chinese and japanese and then i
became a bit of an explorer and then
also
doing it for practical reasons because
it it helped me in my business
in europe so
just do it
well begun is half done
get out there get started and you'll be
i think amazed at all the good things
that will come your way so a bit of a
strange rant but those were the thoughts
that were crossing my mind this morning
thank you for listening bye for now
[Music]
you